[Music]
my research with
high performing folks and folks who are
whose job is to take care of other
people
that number one across the board when
they get themselves in trouble
whether it's psychologically spiritually
mentally whatever
it's because they've stopped listening
to a close group of people
mentors friends who who do you go to you
got a group of people that you trust
that you can
just lay it all out there for i do and
by the way john for me like if someone
were to ask me and if you if you would
go listen to the last you know
20 business interviews i've done i have
said this exact same thing to all of
them my biggest life lesson is you
become who you surround yourself with
and so i am so conscious of community in
fact when i uh
before i married chelsea i knew how
important a spouse was and so i prayed
to god i said god would you send me a
wife who
is mentally stimulating physically
breathtaking and spiritually just on
fire for you so like i was so conscious
of like
knowing the person i'm going to spend
the most time with i i wanted to be a
woman who wanted to be
a world changer and just a great mom and
a great one and and god brought that
person along for me so that's one number
one is chelsea number two
is my business partner one of my best
friends jordan rubin so jordan rubin he
founded a company many years ago called
garden of life sold that and now we
co-founded
ancient nutrition he wrote a book called
the maker's diet so jordan
jordan is about six years older than me
and um and so like even when i was
authoring my first book
uh nancy alcorn who i know we know who
runs mercy multiplied in ministry here i
met him through that ministry
and he gave me some really great life
advice on
publishing a book and starting and
growing a business and all those
different things
so those are two of the biggest ones and
i've got a mastermind or a men's
leadership groom
i'm a part of got guys like colt morton
dan sullivan andrew ruiz dave toohel and
some others that i
i'm just very deeply connected to but i
would say from a mentorship standpoint
um jordan he's a at this point he's one
of my best friends but he's still
again there there's been a lot of
mentorship he's given me over the years
awesome i have some other pastors as
well you have john bevere
uh you know is a friend and uh and
and uh quite a few other pastors that we
look to we actually
for our business we have a our our board
of directors that's out of california
but then we also have what we call our
it's called our kingdom council we have
a spiritual board
where we have nine pastors sit on our
board we do quarterly meetings with them
they speak both into our life and
business
so anyways yeah i'm glad you asked me
because that it is a huge huge part of
my life and making sure that i have
other people
you know hold me accountable that that's
awesome
do you ever have challenges mixing
spirituality
and business yes you know our our board
of first off we have we are super
blessed we have a board of directors
that is incredible
and their values are you know some align
some might be a little bit different
than ours
so i think in the areas of few areas
where they're not completely
you know we might feel a little
different i think that's a challenge and
the spiritual
board we have is is very much like
listen just do what's right in the eyes
of god completely
and the other board is a little bit more
let's toe the line
and just be safe and so i think that you
know for the most part
um you know we there have been
challenges but i think for us
we we have um navigated them with the
best
you know you know wisdom we could and so
i don't know i don't know if i have a
great answer there i'll just say but
yeah
there are yeah i mean there are
challenges as a business because
myself and jordan both have very very
strong faith-based
based values and there are marketing
campaigns people want you to do certain
times and months of the year and other
things and we decide that hey
you know what the marketing campaign the
sort of injustice those sort of things
we're going to fight
we're going to do things our way the way
we feel biblically i'll give you an
example of this and
i hope this is okay to talk about you
know we had uh when um
you know earlier uh in the year we had
there's a
black lives matter and i think a lot of
people wanted us to go and like we were
getting
messages pounding us daily go and
support this organization
and we said you know what number one
give us a day to pray and talk it
through with with our
with with with jordan and i and our
company president and we said you know
what like we want to be about
fighting social and justice we want to
be about doing good in the world and
transforming lives
here's what we're going to do we're
going to go and we're going to start a
scholarship and and
fund uh children the african-american
community
getting a better education fight you
know do these initiatives we're going to
change the way we hire so
we made all of these changes we got
criticism maybe because we didn't
have a certain post on instagram but we
said we want to be the sort of people
that are fighting and ju so i'm just
giving an example
we are very conscious of like we want to
be a light to the world we want to have
an impact
but we want to do it in the way that
jesus would have done it
that's transformative exactly not the
way that because here's what most people
do today
they're like we just want to look good
we're not going to actually do anything
but we want to look good and that's what
you see when you see all of these
celebrities and these people
out there talking about certain things
they're doing almost
nothing gotcha and so i just you know we
want to be the change
and and let let that change be
represented in
like your company will look different
right and your neighborhoods will look
different and the people you come in
contact look different right
that's that's fantastic man so when it
comes to food
movement healthy living i'm gonna ask
you a trick question first and then
we'll get to the real
what is something that would surprise
people
that you are militant about with your
new child
and what would surprise somebody that
you're a lot more lacks with your kid
sure a couple things one um
you know we uh so i used to be under the
impression this is another example where
i'm wrong
where i've been wrong that everything i
eat should be perfect
like i and before i met chelsea she
would tell you she softened me up a
little bit
you know trips to italy and that sort of
thing helped too where it's like him in
tuscany it's like i can't not
yeah pizza and gelato right now but so
that being said
like we actually give her foods that uh
we know she's gonna be exposed to
we we give her as she's growing we give
her a little bit of gluten we give her
some dairy we give her
certain products that if she was doing
in large amounts she may have a
uh reaction or an intolerance to but
that we know like
we our bodies are created we actually
should strengthen our bodies through
getting these micro exposures stress
responses yeah yeah yeah
and so we actually really do that with
arwen to where we're giving her certain
things
uh in small doses to naturally help
support and strengthen her immune system
so that's one thing we we absolutely do
um
so that's that's you at a restaurant and
there's a some like i don't know i'm
just making something up but uh
it's when people come by and see my
daughter eating a
piece of like a cheese pizza it's a
and yeah i think yeah
and here's the other thing i found when
you go to a place like italy and some of
the areas of the world that have the
longest lifespan even japan
that they're not eating perfect there's
the biggest thing
is actually low stress and healthy
relationships they're not psychotic
about it
yeah now they move but they're not
actually they're not lifting weights
they're riding bicycles they're walking
they're swimming
they're gardening they're doing those
things and they're eating very clean but
then they're
once or twice a week they're having a
vacation meal they're having a couple
glasses of wine they're having you know
a little too much you know sugar on
occasion but it's not every day it's
just sort of sprinkled
in it's not you know you know it's it's
not the dominant part of the way they
eat
you